what's up everyone it's Warren and we
have some new leaks about the brand new
Avengers end game footage that was shown
during the Disney shareholders meeting
this happened a few days ago and one of
the shareholders went online to share
the description of what he saw but as it
turns out he left out some dialogue some
pretty important dialogue about how
nebula knows where Thanos is so I'll
read to you what he added and then I'll
read the scene over again in its
entirety quick reminder about my
giveaway if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win five imax tickets all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain okay so Scott laid
wing the Disney shareholder who leaked
the description of the Avengers and game
footage went back to Twitter and said
nebula had a few lines that I didn't
mention from the Avengers scene we saw
at the shareholders meeting I'm using
quotation marks but the words may not be
exact
Steve Natasha and etc are all out the
avengers headquarters trying to figure
out how to find Thanos we hear nebula
say I know where he is and the scene
shifts and she steps out of the shadow
and comes forward she says while he was
perfecting me he'd talk about where he
would go when it was all finished even
disassembled I wanted to please him so I
would ask father where will we go and
his answer was always the same
she then mentions a name or a word but I
didn't catch what exactly it was someone
next to her rody i think says nice fan
o's has a retirement plan and then
that's where it picks up with the rest
of the scene as i described previously
this is really important information
this goes to show that nebula is going
to play a pretty big role in Avengers in
game not just with the Avengers but it
seems like we're going to learn a lot
more about her backstory with feyo's
remember in the comics she plays a very
important part she actually wields the
Infinity Gauntlet and undoes Thanos a
snap and although we may not see that
happen in the movie it does seem like
she's going to play a rather big part
after all she knows Thanos the most out
of all of the people who are still alive
so it does seem like she's going to play
a pretty big role in avengers endgame so
like I said in the beginning I'll go
ahead and read the full leaked
description and I'll put these lines in
there the Avengers in game scene they
showed was at the Avengers
quarters Captain Marvel saying let's go
kill thanos nebula says she knows where
he is she steps out of the shadows and
comes forward she says while he was
perfecting me he'd talk about where he
would go when it was all finished even
disassembled I wanted to please him so I
would ask father where will we go and
his answer was always the same
she then mentions a name or word but I
didn't catch what exactly it was someone
next to her rody I think says nice fan
OHS has a retirement plan rocket says
that it was the biggest energy surge
ever seen on earth when Thanos used the
glove but it was seen again on another
planet shortly after so that's where fan
OHS is retiring to quick exchange
between Captain America Natasha
Bruce rody and Captain Marvel Bruce
asked what guarantee they have this ends
differently Captain Marvel says they
have heard this time rody asked where
she was because they could have used her
before Captain Marvel says a lot of
other planets out there need help and
they don't have Avengers like Earth has
Thor gets up from sitting quietly in the
back walks up to Captain Marvel and
summons his axe it whizzes right past
Captain Marvel into Thor's hand and
Captain Marvel doesn't even flinch and
Thor says I like this one cut to the
Milanoo everybody buckled in Captain
Marvel in the copilot seat rocket asks
who hasn't been to space and Captain
America rody and Natasha raise their
hands and rocket warns them not to puke
in his ship and off they go
a cool reflection of stars in space on
Captain America's eyes as we zoom in on
him and they warp out of there and
that's it for the leaked description of
this scene nebulas lines add a little
bit more to the scene and again they
show us that she's going to play a
pretty big part in Avengers endgame what
do you think about this scene and what
role do you think that nebula will play
in Avengers in game let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Marvel and
Avengers in game as always thank you all
so much for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]